in a busy corner of abuba district a few
people affected by the country's violent
past
meet among them victims
aggressors mediators and facilitators
confront their fears
with hope of finding closure fali seidu
an ex-competent blames injustice to his
tribe and the murder of his friends for
his role
in ivory coast post-election violence
even if you don't commit any crime you
live with stigma just because you were
an ex-combatant
reconciling all sides is the only way to
heal right now we face stigma and
discrimination even if we didn't go to
war
and for those whose loss was so much
greater the recovery remains a long
difficult process ellen kwaku was first
uprooted by the 2002 civil war from the
city of pouake to abijah
only to be left devastated by the
post-election violence
of 2011. at the meeting she cut a figure
of a strong character
a leader but back home she's overcome
with graves
i can't explain to you how my son died
when he saw me he said mom
we fled wawakka only to be in a worse
situation
he looked at me and breathed his last on
the anniversary of his death his father
died of grief
you see i lost my son my house my wealth
almost
everything thousands have been killed in
ivory coast 2002 civil war and the 2011
post-election violence
more than a decade after there's still
much hate and anger
our truth and reconciliation commission
was set up in 2014 to attempt to close
these dark chapters
in ivory coast's history implementing
its recommendations
is taking time because of how deep the
divisions are in a country once
considered
west africa's island of stability
shortly after his re-election last year
president alison water established a
ministry
devoted to reconciling ivorians
previously
the role of reconciliation the healing
process
and all was left in the hands of few
individuals
and organizations
leads the federation of victims of
post-election violence in ivory coast
he says their work is made difficult by
the failure of the country
to appreciate how deep their divisions
are
it's a daily struggle to reconcile
victims and aggressors our objective is
to unite ivorians to live in peace once
again
he says that's helped some to move on
but once that in areas was affected by
the country's crisis
there's still much suspicion mistrust
and in some cases hate
among neighbors and it's reflected in
africa's politics
many here feel unless the government
invests more in confidence building and
trust
the nation may not attend lasting peace
destroyed by both the 2002
civil war and the post-election violence
of 2011.
mohammed idris al jazeera abigail